Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop, where today we're going to be building ourselves a Batman style grappling gun
ooh nice
NO NATE!
Phew!
He's ok
Nice logo :)
retracting abilities to something built by a billionaire bat would have
but it's a lot easier to make and it's still a lot of fun to play with.
The supplies are low cost and easy to
Get your hands on and there's a good chance you already have most of them lying around somewhere
We've got some electrical tape, a ballpoint pen, an old marker, two pencils, a clothespin,
Two wide thickness rubber bands, three paper clips, and a box of dental floss.
Along with our electrical tape, we've also got a hot glue gun that we'll use for some of our attachments.
First, let's take our two pencils and secure them together using our tape
Ooh tape!
it's nice and tape-ey
Snip
Next let's grab our box of dental floss
And we're going to want to attach our pencils on to the bottom of that
We're using the bottom partly because we want to be able to open our floss later
but also because these boxes tend to have a curved top which is a lot harder to stably attach something to
yay glue
Glue Glue Glue
While adding the tape
I want to make sure that none of it
Overlaps with the lid of our container because we do still want to be able to open and close it whenever we need
It feels pretty securely attached. Let's move on to the next step and to do that, let's grab our marker
So we need an empty plastic tube, and we're gonna take that
From the front part of the marker and then we want the back part of the marker
Where it attaches onto the lid the way I've got it right now
We don't need any of the writing nib and there's a little bit of plastic housing down inside the tube right here
So let's cut this off right about here and then we'll cut the rest of the marker tube approximately in half
We don't need the whole cap. We only need about one centimeter of it. So let's mark that spot as well
Now let's cut along these lines
We can use either a razor blade or a hacksaw or something like that
Before I start cutting into that, I am just gonna try and pull the nib out here
We've still got a cartridge full of ink inside this too, which I'm just gonna end up cutting right through
That's alright
Saw ( ( i n c r e a s e ) )
See it stained my saw blade orange
There's the ink cartridge inside for a pen and marker
And now we just need to cut off the end of our cap
(more sawing)
We've now got a hollow tube that we can see right through
We have another piece of tube with the end still on it, which clips nicely into the end piece of our marker cap
Let's set these two pieces aside for a moment and move on to this piece
So this is going to be a sort of guiding barrel for our projectile, which is going to be our grappling hook.
These markers have some little ridges down inside them that help keep that tube of ink in just the right spot
We're going to use those ridges to help guide our grappling hook to right where we want it to go
so if we look closely we can see that the ridges come all the way to the front on one side and
Don't quite reach the back on the other side. We want the front ridges at the very front of our projectile gun
once again
Let's start by using a tiny bit of our hot glue to attach this tube onto the front of this gun
And then we'll go over it with tape to really secure it in place
The body of our little grappling hook launcher is starting to take shape at this point
Let's take a close pin and add it onto the back of the pencils as a firing mechanism
Our little gun doesn't have any power yet
And that's what we're gonna be using our rubber bands for
Let's just cut one of our rubber bands in half to start with
Those rubber bands are going to be attached onto the side of this front barrel
But we can see that if we use the whole rubber band
There's not a lot of power when we pull it back into the clothespin.
that's barely enough to move it at all
So we want to tighten this up and we won't use the whole rubber band
We'll pull it tight until we only have a very small loop just big enough to fit our finger in behind the marker
trim off our excess rubber band here at the front
And now we want to use a small dab of hot glue and then plenty of tape to hold just the front of this rubber band
in place
We don't want to secure the rubber band all along the whole pen body, or there won't be enough elasticity to reach the clothespin
The two rubber bands really have a lot more strength and resistance to them than the one
Most of the gun body is built. So it's time to start making the grappling hook itself
Let's grab our pen and three paper clips.
For this grappling hook we're not going to need most of the internal bits of our pen. Let's take those apart
We can leave the back cap in as just the front of our grappling hook
Mostly, we're just trying to get the tube body of the pen
but let's set it aside because we are also going to want the small plastic collar that the ink cartridge fits into
We now need to bend our three paper clips into a hook shape and attach them onto our pen
Start by taking about the bottom quarter of our paper clip and getting a slight angle into it
You can see that once we attach that onto the pen it will angle away from the pen body and now we need to add
A second Bend to make it more of a hook
Let's Bend our other two paper clips into the same shape as this one
Our three paper clips are bent into hook shape, so now we need to attach them onto the back of the pen
Let's use a little bit of hot glue and then some tape to secure them in place
ooh paperclips
With our three paperclips attached our grappling hook is mostly ready to be used
If it doesn't look like you've got quite enough angle into the hooks
You can still bend them a little bit farther so that they'll grab onto things a little better
Now because our grappling hook isn't going to be much good unless we can pull it back to us
Let's pull out a length of the floss that we've got and attach that onto the back of our hook
it's hard to know exactly how much we'll need but
Let's pull out plenty
Plus, it's just fun to pull off floss.
That should do it. To attach our floss
We're gonna be using that little color that we took off of the ink cartridge and we're going to attach that into the back part of the grappling hook
First, let's feed our dental floss in through the front of that collar and out the side and now with that piece
Extended sideways we can fit this into the bottom of our hook and it should hold it nicely in place
We can also trim off the extra floss
*Snatch*
Grappling hooked!
We can now test fire our grappling hook to see what kind of distance we're getting off of it
Let's pull our rubber bands back into the jaws of our clothespin
And then load the grappling hook in through that tube. It will pull the dental-floss string after it, which is just what we want it to do
Now by pressing down on the clothes pin our grappling hook should fire
Well, looks like after it fired we got to about here with our dental floss, let's add another
18 inches or so and trim it right there
Now we don't just want all of this dental floss just
flying around as we're using our gun and that's what we're gonna use this other piece of marker for this is going to be a
spool
That we can wrap the dental floss around when we're carrying our grappling hook and then when we fire the grappling hook it will all
unravel quickly trailing behind our grappling hook
Let's use a hot glue gun to attach the cap portion of our spool onto the body of our dental floss container
This is a pretty smooth surface, so be sure our glue sticks, let's rough that up using our exacto knife
scritch scritch
With the glue cooled we should be able to pop the body of our marker right off of the cap
This is how we can temporarily attach our floss onto our spool mechanism
Let's just take the end of the piece of floss
Lay it across the cap. And then press the body of our spool down into the cap
This is what will hold it in place
But we also want to wind all of our floss around the spool and it's going to be easier to do that before we attach it
To the cap. Let's take this off and making sure that we leave an inch or two in the back
Let's begin winding our floss all the way around our marker spool until our grappling hook is on a short leash
Just as a quick test we can see that if we just pull this dental floss
It comes off a spool very easily and now we can just take that piece of floss
And once again have it cross over the cap
And then press our spool down into it and it should be held nicely in place
now if we load up our gun by pulling back the rubber band into the jaws of the clothespin we can fit our
Grappling hook down the barrel and we can see that our floss tether isn't just hanging everywhere
It's well attached to our spool and when we fire it
It comes off  nicely.
After we fire the grappling hook we can wrap the floss back up and it's ready to go for another shot
Our little grappling-hook is working pretty well, but I don't think it's quite the style of something Batman would use
so
Let's see if we can take a little bit of paint and tape and make this into something that Batman will be proud to hang
on his utility belt
Hey guys, thanks for watching if you aren't a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club. If you missed our last video or you need to check it out again click up here at the top
Click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should be watching next
That's it for now. Have fun, Be safe and see you tomorrow
Bye  Fam
I said Bye
BYE
BEGONE